what's up guys welcome back to the Jenna
and Julian podcast big pink where we
wanna hype at talk about Jenna Jillian
things amongst the other things we're
recording on kind of a weird night right
now we were just watching the news in
the whole Oh Paris catastrophe went down
yeah today when we were recording this
is Friday November 13th 2015 and we've
been started busting our butts to get
things ready for when we go to Tokyo
next week or we're leaving in a couple
days or a day and yeah it was is a lot
today it's been a very heavy news day it
is difficult to really think about
anything other than the absolute tragedy
that happened in Paris a yes or well I
mean obviously our hearts in thoughts
and prayers go out to every human being
affected by this for those who don't
know you you can catch yourself up but
there was a it was an attack in Paris
over right now the figure is 120 people
confirmed dead which just saying that is
like it's just one it's just horrible
yeah so ah if we see if we see him a
little bit yeah down a work kind of
exhausted we're burning the candle at
both ends be it was kind of a heavy day
see there was also casually an
earthquake in Japan and we're supposed
to fly to Japan very soon so that was
also a minor concern for us you know we
had to figure out where it was and if it
would affect our trip or you know if we
should still go there's a lot of things
happened today yeah and down a little
closer in here
yeah so if if we seem a little out of it
that's probably why yeah um yeah I mean
we're not we're like I sit here and have
all discussion about the Paris situation
I have I have nothing to say there's
nothing there's nothing there's nothing
honestly yeah and it it's just it's just
horrible
you know never we look at it so it's
really really sad our you know our
condolences and thoughts to everyone
affected but it's just it's just one of
those days you know where something
really really evil gets executed and
everyone's kind of left with their jaws
on the floor kind of wondering what the
[ __ ] but uh we we're not going to sit
and talk about that today we we so our
last podcast we had Ricky on mm-hmm and
we recorded that podcast Friday night so
basically a week ago he came over and
when you shut the podcast now not even
20 hours after that we were on that roof
where I got a video of the UFO or rocket
or missile missile it's like a loud
helicopter yeah but yeah so basically
not even a day after we recorded the
last podcast that whole thing went down
and for those who still don't know
basically I caught video of this giant
light in the sky we didn't know what it
was we thought was a UFO apparently it
was tried to missile launch by the Navy
but it's very bright very UFO II looking
and I got very good video of it because
we were on a roof while we randomly saw
so shooting a time-lapse more than that
I was shooting all sorts of stuff for
the vlog and um it was just one of those
things where as crazy coincidence but
basically I got really really good
footage of it and we ran home and
uploaded it and the video kind of went
everywhere but has like it has almost 9
million views right now I don't know how
many it's going to have or it's going to
keep growing but basically yeah new
sites for using in and and a lot of you
guys are tweeting I mean after that
happened like guys talk about
on the podcast this week but we had
already recorded the podcast yeah so we
couldn't do that but we'll you know I
figured we would kind of address that
this week because it was definitely a
wild experience both watching it I would
say watching that thing with my own two
eyes and not on one is was the craziest
part of this whole thing
I mean that to me was the craziest part
is probably were you guys know how
obsessed I am with all things alien if
you're here you a hundred percent if you
if you're listening to the podcast you
have been exposed to my love for
anything unexplained or controversial or
alien or whatever but I've barely even
touched the tip of the iceberg of how
far down that rabbit hole I go yeah um
so I I'm actually a little disappointed
in myself though as we were walking back
to the car we were with Jason and gaps
who've been on the podcast before and
Jason spotted it he spotted it off in
the distance it was like just on the
horizon it looked like a little orange
dot look like a meteor yeah he saw it
first and I was like [ __ ] like I always
see that [ __ ] first and I'm always eyes
on the sky man Seuk ELO's you taught me
everything and it's being in that moment
you know when you see it on Twitter you
see the videos it doesn't really capture
how it feels in the moment to be seeing
something in the sky that is completely
out of the ordinary so you know a lot of
people on their high horses are like oh
you guys are such idiots it's just a
missile like calm down but you have to
understand that when you're living in a
enormous ly populated city you're going
about your daily life and you notice
something in the sky that looks
completely out of place and then it
becomes something as big and as bright
as that missile was it is shocking
because you know you're mixed with these
fear like is it a bomb is that a meteor
is it coming towards us should we run
like your brain goes through so many
things as you're watching it happen
and you know there's videos of people
like screaming yelling like having all
kinds of different mixed reactions and
what I think is important to remember is
that yeah sure in hindsight it's a
missile I guess whatever
aliens I'm still helping France but like
in that moment it is very scary to see
something like that over such a large
city or at least that visible from such
a large city I mean cuz it could be
anything and when it exploded you know
we're like what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is happening yeah there
was nothing like in my mind or memory
that I could draw from to relieve what I
was looking at to like it wasn't like it
was just wasn't like anything I had ever
seen in with my eyes right and that
stuff doesn't occur here on any sort of
regular basis so it's not like you're
being exposed to this every five years
where you're like oh it's just a missile
I know they can't tell us when they're
doing it because that would defeat the
point but I've at least come up with
several different theories as to why
they would do it like that but that's
neither here nor there yeah yeah it was
odd what's interesting though is when we
were up there we spent maybe an hour up
there I would say 55 to 57 minutes out
of that hour we were completely faced
the other direction yeah we were on the
other end of the parking lot
facing the other direction shooting that
way shooting in a different direction
but still away from where the you f er
the missile was towards traffic getting
time-lapses and then when we wrapped
completely finished with everything we
wanted to do you know I had my camera in
hand alright let's go and that's when we
had to walk towards that direction
towards the mountain where the man where
the light came from so we had about like
a 122 maybe a hundred eighty second
window where we would have seen it and
we did and had my camera
it wasn't even it wasn't he just in my
head he was on my camera was on as I was
literally just that fresh off from
finishing shooting and I just go oops
and I turn it up and the whole time I'm
thinking oh yeah no this is great that
I'm recording but I'm not even looking
at my camera I'm just really really
trying to
look at this and my camera is not going
to get any good footage I have a wide
lens on it yeah it's a great lens it's
great camera but it's still wide so it's
going to appear very small little did I
know it would would pick it up
incredibly like it did but yeah I found
it funny that like link said there's a
lot of videos just people screaming the
whole time are looking at it and I was
so like confused that I just I didn't
say a word the whole time and then at
the end I'm like what the [ __ ] was that
yeah like if you actually yes I didn't
have the mic on there because we were
almost [ __ ] well you can live well
the Mike wouldn't picked you up anyways
it's a parable
you know a directional mic so I would
have picked up that way but anyway like
you can hear the yelling of you guys in
the back just like faintly but yeah just
I think my lack of speaking my complete
silence while the thing just kind of
transforms in this guy was just like
indicative of what I was thinking of so
what is this thing yeah so there is just
insane insane experience well yeah I
mean it's insane that we've had a couple
of shared experiences with Jason and
gaps where we just all happen to be in
the right place at the right time one of
us noticed is like something and coyote
you are always there with the camera and
to catch it on tape yeah it is really
cool when you have one of those
experiences like right place right time
and like after I was nervous you know
leaving that parking lot after it you
know the missile it's so bright because
it's passed through the atmosphere and
the sunlight is hitting it at that point
and that's when most people got video
footage of it is because it's so bright
you can't like not see it you know and
it's visible from multiple states so how
big this was and you know was it [ __ ]
say I don't even know it was just so
incredible that you are probably one of
the only people that has that special
video footage of it from sort of start
to finish from when it was visible in
the city of Los Angeles
it's [ __ ] really cool pretty wild you
know the x-files emailed me they did
they want
uh yeah did you do I was like I was like
yeah give him give my YouTube channel
some credit well it's kind of like a TV
show so we can't really cry and I was
like yes you can it's called the credits
and it goes at the end I was like I was
like what do you have any money and
they're like Nozick let me marinate no
you none of that is real no it's not no
they actually inquired okay but um ya
know it's not a news channel they can
throw your name up Wow yeah that's
really cool though yeah um we were
watching no we weren't watching we were
sitting around doing our thing last
night and someone tweeted at me an
episode of UFC embedded which is
basically like the UFC's version of
vlogs they like kind of documental the
week of the fight basically with
fighters were up to and stuff and they
were like Ronda watches your video in
this vlog and I was like [ __ ] because I
used to ought to you have seen abetted
ever like religiously and I'm good [ __ ]
she's sure enough
she's in her hotel room watching my
video and you can hear my voice she
calls me Justin um it's okay it's cool
she tries for the first letter uh she
tried it Julian has interviewed and you
guys know we talked about having her
twice matter one yeah like yeah but I
I'm sure she got if I was Wanda and I
had as much [ __ ] to deal with that she
did I would not remember me either so
seriously is what it is it's really cool
that they offended I'm not offended
you're the first person you said
offended I didn't say it but is really
cool that she watched your video it's
really cool to think you know when you
put something on the internet that
you're like alright I'm putting this on
the internet and then you you see
numbers and you definitely understand
those are people watching it but you're
like alright never once in a million
years crossed my mind that Ronda Rousey
would see that anyone else on my house
saw his numbers like okay yeah
bananas it really puts it in a different
gear realness it's crazy but I like the
whole thing was very confusing three
wrong I know that there was a notice to
Airmen at LAX a couple days before right
yeah which means I was just to them not
to have the public right but listen they
the military the Navy you know
government they can't just be announcing
they're gonna launch test a launch a
test missile because then everywhere you
go in a panic no I'm sorry no every
other country is going to keep their
eyes on what is happening because they
they want to see your [ __ ] test
missile they probably want to see what
goes wrong with it or you know how they
could possibly defeat something like
that because from what I've read the
Trident 2 missile is used often I could
totally be wrong I'm kind of tired right
now but like if someone were to try and
drop a nuclear weapon on Los Angeles
they would use something like the
Trident to missile to blast it up there
and explode it away from him beings
divert bombs yeah
so why other countries would be
interested in that like they want to see
if your [ __ ] [ __ ] works you know what
I mean yeah so they can't really tell
everyone that they're going to do it
because then people that they don't want
to see the results of that are going to
be watching what's your intensity weird
but so the reason why I'm buying into
this was a missile is that they did give
a notice to Airmen at LAX and the
flights were being diverted around to
different parts so there was like a
no-fly zone so that they could test this
missile you know they didn't tell LAX
that they're gonna launch off a [ __ ]
missile so it wasn't like a random
[ __ ] oh my god what is that there was
a preparation beforehand and I this is
one of my theories is that this was
either on purpose to flex muscles to
other countries as to our weaponry
or it was just purely to see how us as
civilians in a populated city would
react to a scenario
like that yeah and I imagine it although
that's kind of a far-fetched theory well
maybe it isn't but you accomplished
exactly what they were hoping for you
know what I mean that someone would
catch the Sun tape and that people would
be like really up in arms and panicky
about it yeah if that's the case one guy
would upload it to YouTube entirely UFO
but what's interesting though is that
you did get a couple phone calls from
Hong Kong or like it you know other
countries that might be interested in
this story or what you saw from for
reasons other than just is it a UFO you
mean yeah like country you know
diplomacy and different things
interesting things about being a missile
it's interesting to think about yeah you
know what I mean no do you think it's a
UFO I don't I mean no you know the
reason I titled it that is because at
the moment [ __ ] did think it was UFO
and what I think was really kind of
frustrating was literally hours after
that thing started to blow up online I
would get calls and emails from really
really you know high esteemed news
outlets saying okay so now but what was
your reaction when you found out it was
it was just a missile and it just
bothered me a little bit that they liked
the moment they hear one thing from the
government up that's the answer but no
one has any skepticism right even even
if it's that giant huge [ __ ] light in
the sky like they hear one word from the
government from the Navy whatever not up
- what was your reaction when you heard
that and I'm like well you know I know
that there's a lot of that floating
around right now but I'm not so sure I
believe anything yet I'm just kind of
letting it like sink into my brain and
collect all the information I can all
these people they they felt very droney
like oh okay we have this information
now what do you think of this
information like did you just have your
opinion swayed on what you thought it
was in the matter of under a second
because you saw the word government and
you saw the word test missile like that
that was frustrating and I got
interviewed by the LA Times about it and
they said that exactly they like oh okay
so what was your reaction when you found
out what it was
and I was like well I don't really think
I know what it was right now like I'm
still a little skeptic you know I'm a
skeptic a little bit and I'm looking
around and I'm not saying I'm like I'm a
crazy UFO like enthusiast or I'm some
giant alien believer or what I am I'll
be in that but for you that's not my
point I know I know my point is that
like you know I think that it's always
important to have a healthy level of
skepticism of anything ever anything
ever and especially when it comes to
whatever the government is telling you
what just happened because I'm sort of
in the boat right now that they could
say that that's a Trident to missile and
I've looked up plenty of videos on
YouTube of other Trident to missiles
being test launch that people have
caught on tape and I'm just not a
hundred percent sure that that's even
what it was like some of the videos of
trying to missiles don't really look
like that at all and you know maybe they
could say hey guys sorry it's the
military this is why I'm not I'm you
know I've sort of ruled out UFO because
of the notice to Airmen at LAX but i'm
maanna Harmsen buying that it is what
they say it was and I'm not buying
anything as to why they would launch it
in perfect view of the city of Los
Angeles
I'm not buying why they did it when they
did it yeah I'm not buying that it was a
successful test there's no doubt that
there's more to it that people don't
know yeah I think honestly if I had to
come up with a far-fetched theory that
this is you know if you like watching
ancient aliens at all and all the the
hype that's around like if ever UFO
crashes or you know that aliens or
whatever can help people come up with
new and better technology that this was
an experimental form of technology that
maybe they've been working on and my and
my crazy alien brain you know maybe
they've acquired from some sort of UFO
spacecraft that they like to keep hidden
for us and they were just [ __ ] trying
something new out I think it's
absolutely naive for any human being on
earth to think that we are the only life
that's just I think it's I think it's
narcissistic it's it's both I like to
think like really of all the
like splendor and Majesty of the
universe like ever it's so unbelievable
to think about you really think that
we're like the only conscious beings or
like that where we are the the best
thing that came out of that really
humanistic Aniston oh yeah yeah but I
don't know I'm not I'm not a hundred
percent buying what they told us and I
think that it's always important to have
a level of skepticism I saw someone had
tweeted you know the only day when
anyone even has a healthy level of
skepticism about about what they read as
a news article is April 1st April Fool
says that is the only day wouldn't
people
everyone's a [ __ ] drone don't just
look at edit at a news article and just
you know pretty much believe every do
their drones [ __ ] is wrong yeah I'm
like it's just I don't know I feel like
there is there is one good thing that
goes with so many good things about
social media and the way that news is
kind of shifting fronts but one of the
really like most important things in my
mind is the way that people are able to
form opinions and gather their own
information you know with the internet
you're able to kind of be everywhere at
once and you're able to take in all the
information that is out there whereas
you know 15 years ago when the news was
the news you were either yeah I believe
that or hey I don't but when you said
you don't you didn't really have a
reason not to because you couldn't do
any other research of your own unless
you had weeks and months on end to go
and research it but now it's like you
know I feel like everyone it's
everyone's duty a little bit to be
skeptical because of what is what you
behold you behold so much information
now you you owe it to yourself you owe
it to your fellow humans in the human
race to be a person who is kind of a
self thinker you know at some times when
you really need to be and things like
this it's just like it was so funny to
me all the old media people I spoke with
we're just so convinced like oh no it's
this cool yeah cool cool can you
everyone which everyone in America
speaking everyone in the world is
talking about this right now
on Twitter everyone yeah it was
worldwide trending for whatever many
hours like go on there and have a
conversation read some things just see
what's going on don't just sit I don't
know no I agree it just got to me I I
agree a hundred percent and I dragged
one Arizona good reporter for refusing
to say that it was anything other than
the torrid meteor shower and I tweeted
at her like a few times that I wanted to
bang my head on something and I could do
a drag Jenna yeah I couldn't feel my
arms because I was so angry at her
tweets because she literally tweeted a
picture of it that someone had taken
from Arizona that looks nothing like the
toward meteor shower the toward meters
would be coming from the east this came
from the West
she didn't even [ __ ] care she's a
meteorologist yes she does [ __ ]
weather so it's not her area of
expertise but it bought I've treated her
like you report the news like what are
you doing this is irresponsible and I
openly tweeted I will drag anybody that
calls this a meteor shower because how
could you possibly look at you know
three seconds after that happened there
were videos and pictures on Twitter like
there's all that information available
to you as someone that reports the news
how dare you look at that video and go
yo it's the torrid meteor shower y'all
know how ridiculously irresponsible yeah
well you gave it to her well she
deserved it like that I mean the rest of
us are you know fending for ourselves
and just you know at least for me what I
was tweeting was as you're realizing
what's happening what's going on that
like you're coming to a revelation of
what it is but at no point was I like
yeah that looks like a [ __ ] it's a
meteor yeah we just saw the coolest beer
do you want how you didn't know what it
looked like that in the first
and then it kept going and turn to
something that we read but you
understand I'm saying yes like yo guys I
just saw the coolest meteors it's acid
nor did we say UFO we were like we don't
know what it was last night I called it
UFO because honestly at the point of
time that I uploaded it it was
unidentified for me I didn't know what
it was it's identified they haven't
released the tried into thing yet what
do you when I uploaded it what do you
mean they hadn't said it's a tried into
Michigan my president yeah so that's why
it's Peter I think along anything for
hours yeah like we thought we were
taking crazy pills and then Khloe
Kardashian tweeted my video right oh
sure got real okay where people were but
then the Navy was like teehee just
kidding guys it was our missile yeah but
they didn't explain why they chose to
[ __ ] logic there's a lot of questions
still unanswered I think that's the
point here it you know aside from the
fact that we were directly involved mhm
there are still a lot of questions that
I think a lot of people would love to
know the answer to
mm-hmm honestly even with the questions
I'd be happy to live with the questions
as long as I got to have that experience
that was one of the most spectacular
experiences I've ever had in my life I
see me same thing standing on that roof
and watching it in person and also
speaking to people that live in the Los
Angeles area that were you know doing
something out of party or like hanging
out in their house and just didn't see
it at all are very upset that they
missed it and I would have been so angry
if I was in that boat because I it was
unbelievable to I'll never forget which
is also why I'm kind of devastated that
they don't tell us when these happened
because I would love to go and watch one
again yeah we should just go on the
[ __ ] well just do more target we're
friends
it was amazing to see it no but it was
also in the moment very scary well
that's what I said to a lot of people
who asked like what I thought it was
like there was one very short moment
when it was doing its whole thing that I
was legitimately wondering if I should
turn around and run yeah you know like
is this gonna explode there gonna be a
sound so they're going to be shrapnel
everywhere is there gonna be [ __ ]
fire
don't [ __ ] know yeah like what guy
what is it do I run my safe like there
was a moment of that like legit fear
because and I think it's important for
people to know that we were just
stargazing like that was real for us
like we watched that and it felt very
very real yeah
well yeah because it was disorienting to
see that it was moving pretty laterally
like across the scale it's somewhat of
an optical illusion but like when it was
moving off of what appeared to be the
horizon you it was disorienting and that
you can't tell which direction it's
going in it wasn't sort of just looked
like it was getting bigger and bigger
bigger like it was coming at you this is
insane
I mean that's it like that's that was
that was it in a nutshell
like also um little Dicky the rapper who
is now kind of exploding right now in
his infinite wisdom he also made a
really really awesome track called
pillow talking and on that track it's my
favorite thing in the world he he
basically it's like a skit comedy rap
track where he goes over this ten
minutes long situation where he had just
slept with a girl and they're having
pillow talk they're talking about life
and everything and they go into aliens
and it's very funny very well-written I
would check that out if I had a moment
if I were you guys it's very good but
that's what I'm reminded of every time I
see someone who's so so against the idea
that aliens exist to talk with the war
yeah that that video was a story of my
life because I've had way too many
conversations with people about that is
there video for it was there's an
updating of the audio track so if you
didn't have his album I believe you can
go and look it up on YouTube and watch
it listen to it but it is ten minutes
long and it is [ __ ] awesome it's not
like a you should turn it on while
you're you know hanging out with your
friends no no no it's like sit down in a
quiet space and listen so we listen to
in the car we decide really
sorry [ __ ] dying laughing um but I
hope you guys got something out of us
discussing this in our experience with
it um right yeah I'm that one time I
when we're in Santa Monica and we saw
something in the sky made you pull the
car over yeah yeah that is the only time
I believe that I have ever seen in
person with my own eyes a UFO so I was
left with the crushing disappointment of
this not being an alien thing and it
just being a government [ __ ] military
Navy thing so I was a little I was a
little sad a little disappointed because
I felt in the moment that I was a
witness of something spectacular but you
know it was really great I'm really glad
that I saw it and I'm really glad for
you that you got that video and yeah I
saw the raw file I have the only copy of
that footage that it's still like 100%
uncompressed HT and I'll keep it forever
do it I wanna know and then in the
comments what you guys think about like
or if you're watching us on YouTube the
comments or just tweet us yeah like what
you guys think this was are you buying
that it's a Trident 2 missile do you
think it's a different type of missile
do you think that this was an exercise
for them to see how the population would
react to something surprisingly
absolutely we want to hear you guys are
saying all as always be respectful of
other people's opinions no matter what
they are for sure even if even if you're
hardcore this is a [ __ ] UFO yeah do
that like do you yeah and it's a
conversation just have a conversation
yeah but yeah we definitely would love
to hear input because we love scrolling
through the comments on these podcasts
and really kind of like having the other
side of the discussion come back to us
yeah unfortunately we will not be
podcasting next week yeah we as you guys
know are going to be in Japan when
you're watching this we will be in Japan
we're going there for a short short but
sort of extended period of time to do
YouTube FanFest for Jenna and with with
the stockpiling of everyday everything
that we're kind of doing we just don't
have the resources to podcast from Japan
which has gotten to the point where we
that how to do that
not so next week we will be taking off
the podcast we'll miss you guys greatly
but we will be back the following week
so often the following Monday there's
just too many things can go wrong if we
just like tried to podcast inch and and
I'm let me tell you guys a chance if we
were bad me waitin upload a podcast from
Japan it wouldn't be a nice relaxed
happy conversation we would be a little
bit stressed and a little bit kind of
like frazzled with the fact that we
don't even know if it's going to be
uploaded yeah
hopefully that's cool thank you guys for
hanging out as always thanks for
contributing in the comments and we'll
see you guys in two weeks yeah you miss
you but you will catch us on the other
stuff yeah yeah bye guys